a funeral will take place today for one
year old twins who died after their
father left them in a hot car apparently
by accident juan Rodriguez is charged
with manslaughter criminally negligent
homicide and endangering the welfare of
a child prosecutors have not yet decided
whether to proceed with the case there
have been 24 hot car deaths this year
after 52 last year Niki batiste is
following this case Nikki how long could
the legal case last Anthony good morning
it's expected to last several weeks as
prosecutors search for any clues that
the father could have left his kids in
the car on purpose but the family
insists it was simply a horrible
accident mr. Rodriguez is heart
wrenching and heartbroken outside a
Bronx courthouse thursday juan rodriguez
and his family stood in tears as their
attorney pleaded to the Bronx da for
forgiveness we're appealing to her sense
of justice to do what we believe to be
the right thing and that is to dismiss
these charges the 39 year old Iraq war
veteran was charged after police say he
left his one-year-old twins
Phoenix and Luna in a hot car last
Friday he found them strapped in their
car seats after his eight-hour work
shift as a social worker at the VA
hospital we believe that at the
conclusion of them evaluating all the
facts all the evidence and everything in
this case they will come to the
conclusion that this was a horrible
tragedy
temperatures in New York City last
Friday reached 85 degrees inside a car
that number could jump to about 105
degrees in just 10 minutes in a
statement the family attorney said they
will appeal to the state legislature to
pass a new law that would ensure that
all vehicles are equipped with a device
that alerts parents to the presence of
their children he has nothing at all to
harbor and hide other than to feel
misery and sorrow about what happened in
this case they really have to be willing
to open up their entire lives to
investigators CBS News analyst Ricky
Clemens says prosecutors will likely
search through Rodriguez cell phone
records an online search history to try
to prove a motive but she says it is
also on the Rodriguez family to prove
that this was simply a memory lab
oops they have to be willing to say talk
to my neighbors talk to my relatives
talk to the people that I work with and
not hold anything back because that's
the only way that a prosecutor can be
sure or it sure as one can be that this
really was an accident and not a plan
Rodriguez next court hearing is set for
August 27th to try to prevent more
deaths both houses of Congress are
debating bills that would standardize
child monitoring alerts on all passenger
vehicles seems like a no-brainer to me
yeah it sure does this is so
heartbreaking it's so heartbreaking it's
interesting I was asking one of our
colleagues who has three young children
if he could imagine leaving his kids in
the car he said yeah I'm so busy I'm
tired
medical studies that have been done that
have shown that people do it quite often
in fact because of the way our brains
are wired we get into a mode where we're
just going along doing the things that
we do it's a routine and it can happen
to anybody they say just like you might
forget to stop at the grocery store sad
Nicky thank you